Coming off of the skyscraper highs of episode 3 I
think some people may find episode 4 underwhelming
in comparison, but it’s still a great overall
package. It may be slow at parts, however,
that’s necessary in creating a realistic pace.
The scenes in between this time all felt like
they had a purpose and I wouldn’t classify any
of this as filler like I’ve seen people say.
A lot of this material relates to Ellie trying
to chip away at Joel’s viewpoint of Ellie being
cargo. Hearing him say that was very crushing and
it seems like Ellie wants a better relationship
because she first asked Joel if she was family to
him. She’s been trying really hard to bond with
him and this resistance he gives off makes their
dialogue scenes really good. It offers a point of
conflict within their relationship of whether
or not Joel will open up more in each moment
and if Ellie will become Sarah in Joel’s eyes. In
each episode so far there has been a progression.
Like in the last episode, Joel and Ellie were
barely on speaking terms, and now that they are,
Ellie is trying to further push that line to
Joel liking her company. Even for this episode,
their relationship starting point is vastly
different from where it ends. That’s why I think
some of these scenes like the car ride dialogue
and the campsite setting were so important because
it sets up a point in their relationship that
they then progress from later on. And again,
these are really entertaining moments like with
Ellie reading jokes to Joel and trying to make
him laugh, and her discovering a porn magazine.
It’s a very human and awkward moment and Ellie
using these avenues is a clever way to bond with
Joel. Her attempts at humor are endearing and is
a direct contrast to the lifeless nature of the
world and even Joel. She’s essentially slowly
re-invigorating him and seeing this process no
matter how slow it may be will always be great to
watch. Like I love this moment where she delivers
her first joke and Pedro Pascal has an extremely
subtle expression as to him kind of liking it,
but suppressing it. You can see his tense face
partially ease up and I think this was a good
first step visually for Joel to relax a bit. This
recurring beat for their characters I think acts
as a good checkpoint for us to directly compare
their growth throughout the episode. Because we go
from Joel tolerating her jokes to finally giving
in and delivering off a warm laugh. So the plot in
this episode may not pop off, but I still love the
dialogue and the type of relationship that Joel
and Ellie have in the show. I also find it kind
of weird how people are saying this episode isn’t
very good, but yet this features the most of Joel
and Ellie together. And I thought that’s what
people wanted so much. Because from a game to
show adaption for this episode, it’s almost 1 to
1 besides the inclusion of Kathleen. I think her
character felt a bit off because how is this
seemingly non-powerful character in charge of
this revolutionary group when she’s surrounded by
these other characters who look visually stronger.
Her brief scenes when talking to everyone didn’t
exude a lot of confidence and she didn’t give off
strong leader vibes. Also, her introductory
scene didn’t land as hard as it felt like it
was intended because of how much missing context
there was surrounding these two characters. The
writing here tells you enough to understand
what’s going on, but I don’t think we share
a similar emotional connection to what was going
on. Then when she comes back in mid-way through
her speech to execute the doctor and then goes
back outside again felt weird pacing-wise. To me,
this wasn’t the most compelling introduction for
a new villain character and I think it could have
had a slightly better execution. That and the
nature of her character I feel like would have
a hard time convincing all of these people with
her lies and manipulation. It makes me want this
guy who actually is the voice actor for Tommy
in the game to be the villain. His design is a
lot more unique and badass and doesn’t resemble a
karen who probably used to be a soccer mom. This
overall group though I think is an interesting
exploration as to if a people-run government is
better than the one prior. It illustrates how
selfishly human-driven this group is through
Kathleen’s character and is mostly her using
people to accomplish her own goals. It creates a
much more personally driven and fleshed-out threat
that surrounds Joel and Ellie in this setting
because in the game these were basically unnamed
people who wanted loot. Which we can go from this
and talk about the ambush because this was a
horrific scene. This was a perfect re-creation
from the game and every detail was replicated
with immense precision. Starting out I love the
quick reactions that Bella Ramsey gives off where
she’s shocked and dismayed about how Joel is about
to run over this guy asking for help. Then them
crashing into the laundromat was a crazy stunt and
it looked very realistic. Like there was obviously
no way for them to cheat this since they literally
crashed a car into this building and you can see
the stunt actors in the car taking on that crash.
Easy 10 out of 10 stunt. The shootout following
this was equally good and the aspect about this
scene in particular that I loved was the sound
design and music. The shots were so loud,
you could hear the base of each shot, the bullets
penetrating every single distinct surface making
each shot sound unique and realistic, the raiders
mocking and yelling at our characters like the
NPC’s from the game, and the music slowly building
the entire time making the eventual confrontation
of violence that much better. Then the music eases
off as Joel kills one of the raiders in a release
of tension. Just a perfect 1 minute of television
that doesn’t stop here because we now transition
into a more suspenseful moment as the raider
enters the building. Seeing this moment from the
perspective of Ellie enhances this because it’s
more tense not knowing who has the advantage or
who is about to die in the room behind her. Even
when Joel shoots the intruder we still shortly
question the fact if Joel was the one who shot or
got shot. Then the scene keeps going when we think
everything is fine to then having another raider
surprise us from the back door. From a writing
perspective, this entire scene is so genius
because it breaks up the action into three varied
parts. We have the initial explosion of action
that is the car crash and the shootout, the more
suspense-driven moment of hiding from the raider,
and the twist of thinking we are in the clear
to then throwing another dire obstacle at our
protagonists. It creates a good and balanced flow
throughout the action scene. Then the last moment
allows Ellie to finally save Joel and she shoots a
human being, which on its own is another important
ordeal to explore. This is a masterful scene from
writing to execution and the screams and pleading
coming from this poor guy is insanely haunting.
Like honestly one of the best performances from
an extra that I’ve seen in a while. Him crying
out for his mom really blurred the lines as to if
Joel and Ellie were the bad guys in this scenario
because despite them defending themselves, they
are still executing this kid who is no longer a
threat. But sadly it’s necessary for them since
he can offer the enemy intel. Having the death
of this guy play out through the perspective of
Ellie is a double positive. We can see her rich
performance as she deals with this traumatic
experience and by not directly focusing on the
death visually it doesn’t make the violence feel
gratuitous. The kind of impact this has on Ellie
is very nuanced because emotionally it’s affecting
her, but her practicality overrides that because
she knows that they are still in danger and she
needs to function like an adult. This kind of
perseverance makes me love Ellie because she’s a
strong character, despite being a child. She’s not
immediately becoming incapacitated to emotions
and her instinct of survival is still operating
at full capacity. An overall great acting moment
for Bella Ramsey. This whole plot point allows
Joel to finally make an attempt to act like a
father. Ellie has done an unthinkable task of
shooting someone as a kid, and Joel can’t help but
feel guilty for having put her in that situation,
regardless of whether or not it was forced upon
them. This to me is what I would identify as
the turning point for their relationship together.
Through this traumatic experience, they are deeply
and inherently entangled now and it is inescapable
to not deal with the immense emotional baggage of
executing someone. Joel was trying his hardest
to keep his relationship with Ellie at a surface
level, but he would be doing a disservice to
himself as a father if he didn’t try to console
Ellie. And since this trait has been unlocked
within Joel we now see him give in to Ellie’s
humor and before he breaks in a fit of laughter at
the end he makes his own joke towards Ellie here.
This natural progression between Joel and Ellie
is painstakingly detailed and every interaction
that they have feels important. That’s why I would
never classify their earlier scenes together as
filler because it’s necessary build-up to make
this eventual turn even more powerful. Because
the second Joel lets loose and finally laughs, is
probably going to be one of my favorite moments in
the show. Such a wholesome moment with excellent
long awaited pay-off. Then for the last aspect I
loved was the detail of Joel turning over in his
sleep to where his bad ear was the one exposed.
Which explains why Henry was able to sneak up
on them. A great writing moment that perfectly
explains itself if you paid attention. For
this episode, I have seen a lot of people
say that it should have been combined with
the next one because it feels incomplete,
but I think Joel and Ellie’s personal journey
offers a good endpoint for episode 4. Plot-wise
it does end on a cliffhanger, but we don’t know
how long the next episode will be. For all we know
episode 5 could be over an hour long and if they
combined these two episodes it could have been 2
hours long which would be getting ridiculous.
So a slightly under 50-minute episode I think
is perfectly acceptable and it does enough within
its time to be satisfying. It may not go as hard
as the first 3 episodes, but that’s really tough
competition in of itself from how amazing those
ones were. You can’t really have 10 out of 10
episodes constantly and having an 8 every now
and then is natural. Especially since this episode
gives our characters a bit of a breather and a big
chance to develop. Thank you for watching and
by the way, the next episode airs on Friday
since HBO doesn’t want to air episode 5 against
the Superbowl. So Imagine being cowards HBO.